encontramos en la ciudad de bach mud una
ciudad ubicada en el corazón de la zona
del donbass y que pasaba a ser
estratégica en esta gran batalla que
libran las tropas ucranianas por el
control de esta región que es el
objetivo de las tropas rusas en la
actualidad está no solamente la capital
militar en la actualidad sino también
por ejemplo aquí llegan la mayoría de
heridos que vienen desde diferentes
frentes hacia atrás estaría al frente
del issys chang y se verá dones que los
rusos intentan en los últimos días
bloquear su acceso a través de una
carretera que es bastante estratégica en
esta zona del país estas dos ciudades
estarían básicamente asediadas en la
actualidad pero también de la zona de
popa hasta donde cierran que buscan
crear un corredor hacia la zona de sob
ians que tira allí las tropas rusas
vienen desde el norte de la región de
jarque y va así que esta ciudad es hoy
en día estratégica pero lo ha cambiado
muchísimo en los últimos días desde que
la visitamos por última vez muchísimas
personas se han ido la artillería y los
ataques suenan
es más cerca e incluso las tropas rusas
han llegado no están muy lejos de aquí
dicen que la tienen cercada o por lo
menos se acercan desde dos frentes
diferentes y hablando con algunas
personas dicen que están buscando partir
porque cada vez sienten más la cercanía
de las fuerzas rusas aunque los
ucranianos dicen que están reforzando
sus posiciones y la van a defender como
parte estratégica de esta región del
donbass